hey folks it's a tie route and Eric take
here what's up to discuss will the war
cry yeah it's been almost 10 years now
yes we've uh we've worked wed what three
days away from the 10-year mark as the
recording of this video begins it's two
days two days is it two days but if you
had to 23 you're the one that told me
the 23rd yes yeah okay anyway so real
quick off the top what is new like if I
i just signed up back onto it i just
signed up on i start playing two days
ago so what can i get well let me focus
more and tell you about the event that's
going to give you a bunch of stuff
that's kind of more pressed for free and
kind of won't hopefully take in you or
anyone else too much time to get or
achieve yeah first and foremost if
you're playing the game and you're
subbed right now you get the molten
Courtney the molten Corgi yes this like
a pet right yes this is a pet that a
companion that runs along with you has
different manner isms the funniest one
of course for me is it does this little
kind of like bud scoot on the on the
ground is it leave like a fire trail yes
it leaves its molten fire trail that the
Corgi then decides to kind of double
back and investigate and sniff it so he
sent so that he's like he's like a true
molten dog he's like he sniffs his own
excrement I guess so and that's for
everyone that's online currently correct
yes that's correct and the event just
some people know I believe it started
today which is a 21st and ends January
sixth so I'm sure if you kind of sub
within that time frame i'm sure you're
fine you got one percent sure but i
would assume that would be the case so
the molten corgi can be others sign up
now and you have till the 6th do it
folks okay so speaking of molten Corgi
yeah what's up with the molten core so
long the core is back in some capacity
it's a part of the event you can do it
in the looking for raid tool it's still
a 40-man raid so you basically go into
the like dungeon finder so to speak you
go to actually it's sorry it's the raid
finder you go in there you you know you
select your role in the raid dps
or tank uq there and then it drops you
into a 40-man raid and you do mole in
the course there's the nine bosses the
trash everything and surprisingly when I
did it last night the trash is actually
harder than the bosses interesting yeah
so basically make sure you listen to
whoever's leading the raid generally
someone likes to take charge and kind of
tells everyone hey you should be this
you should do that he'll do this and go
through that my experience was a little
slower than i would have liked it to be
because there's just people that I think
maybe plate later didn't play molten
core so they just thought that oh I can
do this but like i said the trash has
some some things I does that stuff
doesn't do now and so it's kind of hard
I mean leading a 40-man team into
anything is difficult I don't care if
it's in wow or if it's like in real life
but yeah if you finish if you finish
molten core there's two things you're
guaranteed to get the third one of them
is the core hound mount which is massive
you've seen it no you should head that's
the two-headed beast that you're on yep
and that gives that's just aesthetic
aesthetic is a mount it does what every
other mount does except it took you two
are down okay we cool the other one is
actually affects you in the game it's an
epic helm that you get it's from the MC
original MC Rae despite its a fiery
crown yeah it is a 640 I level item that
you can use right away it'll help you
because most of the stuff that you're
getting right now isn't a little 640 so
that's a nice thing to get each class
has its own kind of like a helm that
caters to them their class yeah and so
yeah definitely do it for that reason
and then there's also two things that
you can maybe get it's just a chance
drop kind of thing one of them is
another kind of companion it's a fiery
guy that's like has armor looks pretty
cool and then the other thing is this
kind of enchant or imbuing of your
weapon that makes it like fiery so I
suppose yeah aesthetics again it's
amazing what how much easier people have
it now
the one I first played this game Thank
You dozen for we're getting the 40-man
grouped together was a bigger challenge
by far yeah i'm looking for a doctor no
they did not know it was a nightmare hi
there's one more big final thing yeah
it's they brought that kind of a classic
style PvP battleground yeah it's
terrible versus the south shore it's
pretty much a 40 vs 40 Alliance horde
battleground yeah I don't know if I was
playing it wrong but I tried it once
today and its last an hour it has an
hour timer it's all you yeah I saw you
with your epic mount going on there and
do your whatever your two-headed yeah
two-headed bull dog you got there and
it's like you're supposed to get that
like a 10,000 score okay well my team
only got to about a thousand five
hundred which is absurd for about an
hour that was basically just a lot of
honor farming basically we kill them
can't their graveyard keep killing them
that's you get points and that's how you
get points um so what made you stop at a
thousand because the time for how long
it took so i'm not sure if is there
another way to get more exactly i'm not
sure yeah we did something wrong where
we're supposed to be doing something
else objectively but if you look at the
map it's kind of just like well there's
these two points and I guess there's
these kind of side points but nobody
ever deviated it I think everyone would
want to just to fight each other that's
kind of just how it is Hawaiian scored
they want to represent their their clans
and whatnot so there's a lot of four TVs
40 at the first time I actually started
to fight and we kind of grouped up
together my computer can even handle it
or just like there's 80 people doing a
bunch of stuff and my computers over
framerate just goes it's gone to it and
I just diagnosed like oh okay well um
that's interesting i think for all you
folks that are considering playing the
new Warcraft or the work of expansion
you have until tuesday january six to
get your free molten corgi yeah most
likely most likely yeah yeah can I saw
Mike were you I don't think so people
have been selling mounts though of
course they are of course alright well
thanks Eric for the update on worlds of
Draenor and maybe you
we can go and cause some damage with her
molten queries yeah I can't wait a mine
eat its own excrement because that's
what I'm most excited for yeah we'll see
all right take online
you